hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about how to get rid
of acne fast okay and this is getting
rid of the root cause the problem with
most people trying to get rid of their
acne is they're just treating the acne
directly and that's treating the symptom
they never get to the root cause and
they they make some mistakes choose
mistakes scrubbing your face with
cleansers that's a very bad idea why
because you have all this friendly
bacteria on your skin they're supposed
to protect your skin and you basically
scrub it off so you're sterilizing your
skin and then you wonder why it comes
back or acne comes back or you have
other issues so scrubbing the face
really really hard and in with cleansers
is not a good idea I'm not saying don't
clean your face but don't start
scrubbing I made the mistake of that I
had really bad acne in high school and I
would scrub and trying to I think would
be some like blackhead and dirt that I
described off not good it never worked
antibiotics what happens to antibiotics
it will help with acne but it comes
right back even worse because you kill
off the good in the back of bad bacteria
you create strains very strong resilient
strains with bad bacteria that now don't
work against antibiotics and so it's not
a long term correction accutane is a
kind of a synthetic version of vitamin A
which does work but it has some slight
minor complications like nosebleeds
infertility blindness I think it's off
the market now if I'm not mistaken but
these are some mistakes that people make
so what we need to do is we did the
secret is to find out what's really
causing the problem in understanding
what the problem really is okay so that
has to do with understanding what the
sebaceous gland is this is spaceless
gland is a gland right underneath your
acne that is creating the problem so
here's what's happening you have like
five different situations you have extra
tissue tissue being formed you know in a
form of like a little flake a dryness an
extra skin nodule then you have a plug
poor okay and then also can give you
whiteheads or blackheads which really
has to do with this
tissue kind of plugging up that poor you
have inflammation
it's complained red painful
you have unfriendly bacteria in there
that are feeding off the oil and that
oil is called sebum okay that's like the
waxy oily thing that's supposed to
lubricate the skin so you have excess
oil or see them and then you have
enlarged gland okay all these things are
happening and that's really what acne is
it's not just one thing so my whole
thing is let's get deeper let's see what
we can do to correct the original reason
why it's there in the first place okay
well the unique thing about the
sebaceous gland is it's very highly
sensitive to hormones specifically
androgens which is like a male hormone
and even estrogen both of those hormones
okay now the way that you know it's more
estrogen related usually in females and
you would notice if during your cycle or
right before your cycle it gets worse
okay it might be maybe it's even on one
side of the face which means it's if
it's on the left side it's on the left
ovary because the ovaries repetitively
go back and forth each month and release
the egg and produce more hormones so
what happens if you have it more on this
side that means the left ovary is
pumping out too much estrogen okay so it
could be estrogen especially which
related to your cycle or could be
antigen so let's just let's just start
with the androgen situation antigen one
form of androgen is called testosterone
men and women have testosterone men have
it in more mouths larger amounts women
do still have it in certain amounts you
need it but if you're a female you don't
need much of it but in this situation
you're pumping out too much and too much
antigen will increase the sebum the oil
the size of the gland itself and extra
tissue so that's really what it's doing
now my question is why why are you
producing too much androgen right you
say well I'm going through puberty or
whatever
even menopause can do it right well
there's a couple reasons for that number
one you may have a condition called PCOS
polycystic ovarian syndrome I put a link
down below if you've never heard about
it before but that's basically a
situation where you're female and your
ovaries are pumping out too much and
Ojin okay and the three big symptoms are
acne hair loss or alopecia or facial
hair okay a deeper voice as well so
those are the symptoms but while we're
on this topic let's just talk about what
causes PCOS it's really high levels of
insulin okay and it's a condition called
insulin resistance if you look this up
sometimes in the medical literature
it'll say that PCOS is associated with
insulin and then in a some associated
it's caused by insulin because every
single time you improve the insulin
situation the PCF goes away so you might
want to learn more about that if you you
don't know about insulin resistance okay
and you have acne you need to read some
of the videos I'll put a list them down
below because it's probably one of the
most important things that you can
understand about because it's so simple
to fix this thing if you know what it is
and what to do and then you can actually
kill two birds one stone
handle the PCOS handle the antigen
handle the acne - okay so insulin very
important to handle that naturally so
that's one cause the other cause is that
you have too much of a certain enzyme
that is converting your testosterone
into something called DHT that's just a
very powerful form of testosterone so
DHT is like 10 times stronger than
regular testosterone okay so there's too
much of the certain enzyme that's just
making way too much strong testosterone
in your body so now why would that
happen right well one of the reasons is
that you don't your vitamin A deficient
so vitamin A will actually help reduce
that enzyme okay and that's probably why
accutane works because accutane is a
version of vitamin A a synthetic version
so I would start taking vitamin A in the
form of extraversion cod liver oil okay
a high quality cod liver oil get the
extraversion you can get it on Amazon
it's a little more expensive but it's
really good for your skin so vitamin A
will help the skin greatly in improving
this situation the vitamin b5 is another
vitamin that also works with vitamin A
and it helps reduce acne that's another
remedy also to help this enzyme be Lord
and then zinc zinc is very very powerful
for getting rid of acne because it
lowers this enzyme okay so so we have
lowering the insulin okay adding vitamin
a in column oil and also increasing b5
in zinc those are the things that I
would do if I had acne right now I wish
I would have known about this in high
school because I would have done this it
would have cleared things up very nicely
now let's shift gears over to estrogen
so if you have an estrogen problem
that's a little different now what could
cause an high estrogen there's a lot of
things that can cause it but the big
cause is a liver dysfunction
okay the liver is not eliminating the
bad estrogen that's in your body there's
an enzyme in the liver called aroma
taste similar to this enzyme but
basically it will take the estrogen
testosterone that you have and switch it
over to estrogen okay so now here you
are you know you don't have this problem
you have a different issue over here and
that made me come from a liver issue and
this can happen in men and women but
here's the symptoms or the problems with
the liver you could have a fatty liver
which a lot of people have or scar
tissue deliver a cold liver cirrhosis
that comes from the inflammation in the
liver from that eating or a virus like
hepatitis something like that or even a
fatty liver fatty liver will then turn
into cirrhosis over time and again these
these are not isolated situations you
could actually have insulin resistance
that creates the fatty liver
then causes this over here so it's not
just always cut and dry so what I'm
saying is that you have to look at acne
as a clue and pull a string and get your
body healthy the skin is the largest
organ in the body and it gives us clues
on what's going on inside you can tell a
lot about a person's health by their
skin so these are just kind of
indicators you want to use to try
different things so liver dysfunction
okay so that can keep your estrogen time
because now your liver cannot detoxify
these harmful estrogens other things
that can cause this high blood pressure
medications specifically calcium channel
blockers will do it
antibiotics will increase the estrogen
alcohol will increase estrogen it's very
estrogenic yeah heartburn medications
have been linked to high levels of
estrogen antidepressants will increase
your estrogen so all these people are on
medications and they don't know why
they're now they're getting acne because
it's doing this right here
okay so now what do we do if we have
those issues we want to start eating
healthier of course the best food for
the liver would be cruciferous
vegetables okay I'm going to put a link
down below that would be like kale
broccoli Brussels sprouts
there's another remedy that I like and I
put a link down below for more
information it's it's a protocol dim and
dim is like 25 times stronger than
regular cruciferous it's a super
concentrated version of cruciferous that
will really help handle the estrogen
dominance and help acne it's really good
results with that and then the last
thing we'll talk about is stinging
nettle root that is a plant that will
also lower this enzyme and clean up the
excess estrogen in your body
okay so we got cruciferous dim or
either/or or thin stinging evolute
that's really good for the liver of
course apply the information of insulin
which I'm going to put the link below
again there's a lot of information in
this video you can go back and research
it but these are the things that I would
do if I had acne and
there might be other medications that
you can take to get rid of it fast but
it comes back so this is the best way to
correct it fast so it doesn't come back
it's more of a permanent thing so I hope
this helped and put your comments below
thanks for watching